you watch a [ __ ] ton of movies right
yeah I watch a lot of movies I I also
try to go to the theater as much as
possible it's really fun in Japan it's
nice did you get okay you loved I don't
know if you had this in America before
you talk about movies when you go to the
theater in Japan uh you get your popcorn
you get your drink and get the straw
right and it has like a drink slot and
it goes in the drink holder oh that's
cool you like swing it around dude we
don't have that here but I know when I
had this I was like this is like a game
Japanese Ingenuity man like you can fit
so much stuff and I don't have to carry
it okay uh what do you think is like one
of the best moves you've watched in like
recent memory
oh it's tough yeah what would you say it
is yeah it's tough as well because I
don't I get I get it in Japan so the
release schedule is [ __ ] like some
movies come out the same time some come
out like eight months later and I don't
even realize that's true
um or if it's detective Pikachu we got
it first for some reason oh yeah we yeah
yeah ah [ __ ] recent memory what's a
really good movie I watch I can tell you
the best worst movie I've ever seen it
came out this year it's called moonfall
anyone seen moon no no it's a it's a
disaster movie where the moon
mysteriously gets out of orbit and it's
gonna crash into Earth you went to the
theater yep it is without a doubt the
best experience I've ever had it is a
two and a half hour ride two and a half
hours and it feels like 20 minutes I was
I was upset it wasn't longer it was so
impressively bad in every aspect you
could imagine but in all of the right
ways it was magic and what was it just
like what made it like bad I I just like
legitimately everything about that movie
was bad but really beautifully bad right
right like
I don't want to spoil it but everything
happens I'm not gonna watch it you
should watch it really you should
absolutely watch it that's like my
favorite type of videos right what's
your favorite bad movie then
like the classics like the room and
stuff like yeah room obviously
um oh man like trolls too yeah what
about uh the brain what's it now brain
Neil Breen Neil Breen I'm here now
Double Down twisted pair you know them
old God damn oh my God I am a bad movie
all of the turbo shitty movies
yeah and moonfall is the best bad movie
wow okay and that came out this year
came out this year is it still in
theaters or is it no it's on Prime now
so I can't remember the guy's name like
the main character like he's a big actor
but the guy from Game of Thrones that
plays Sam is in it right yeah yeah
Samwell Tully yeah he's in it and it's
directed by Roland Emerich who does like
day after tomorrow 2012.
you know he made a new one and he was so
proud he said that he because this movie
flopped yeah I can't imagine why but it
didn't do well shockingly and he was so
salty he's like it's because of those
[ __ ] Marvel movies no one knows how
to make a good movie anymore like Moon
fall oh my god oh it's so good oh I
think out of all the films I've watched
this year in the theater I want to say
60 or 50 I didn't really enjoy that much
yeah that's why I was kind of like yeah
you know it's fine them a Marvel movie a
lot of the Marvel ones I watched this
year I thought were like okay yeah that
was a Marvel movie I did it Top Gun was
surprisingly good Top Gun was good
that's probably the best one I watched
this year I can't think what else came
out everywhere oh I think everywhere
unfortunately didn't come out in cinemas
in Japan
yeah I watched online
um I'm trying to think what else came
out this year the Batman come out this
year I really like the Batman these guys
didn't really like it that much do you
write the Batman yeah I thought it was
good I thought it was very good yeah I
like I like I'm obsessed with um Robin
pets oh yeah it was a good time no I
haven't watched the White House either
yet good time is one of my favorite
films never watch it it's if you watched
um uncut gems yes it's great it's uncut
Jam so with Robert Pattinson and even
more anxiety oh perfect so it's how old
is so good uh
2017. yeah yeah you should watch it it's
really good it's he is when he was doing
this binge of like weird films that yeah
yeah he was doing it was it was like I'm
not that Twilight guy anymore you know
was not very good Swiss army man though
oh amazing film
and I've never seen that is that is it
as weird as it looks from like the
trailers and [ __ ] yeah yeah okay it's
[ __ ] weird but it's so good I can't
explain like it's just something about a
perpetually farting dead body of Daniel
Radcliffe is the funniest thing in the
world and it's like done in like and
it's told in like kind of a serious tone
right and it's just like it's amazing I
thought I thought I thought it was gonna
hate it he's made his bank oh yeah he's
just chilling
I'll do whatever I want isn't he just
doing a little theater now yeah there's
a lot of fears yeah
good them okay what is the
worst anime you've watched as of late so
I've been on this I started this a
couple months ago I wanted to watch
every shitty anime ever made to find the
definitive worst one yeah so I mean I
did helter Heaven helter Skelton
skeleton thank you yeah you watch Miles
and destruction yeah
[Music]
I haven't gotten there yet that one's oh
my God yeah I think you'd love gazi
swing in dub okay in dub yeah a lot of
the shows are shittier in dub yeah I've
watched the abunai sisters
wow what a throwback yep holy [ __ ] funny
thing about God he's doing you know who
made it no the creator of Gundam really
I'm 100 serious yeah wow
and it's [ __ ] amazing huh I don't
know what was he on I don't know
honestly watch guys it's only three
episodes you're it's it's like to me
it's the room of anime you know 100 it's
like so bad that it's good so what's
what's the worst one you've seen all
right so far I'm on EXO arm and I've
been on X arm for over a month and a
half it's so [ __ ] bad it's like I'm
determined to finish all these awful
anime yeah when the trailer came out
everyone was like what it's watching it
is even worse it's so bad it's like you
keep playing with action I couldn't get
past like episode two I'm on episode
three and it's miserable
why are you doing this to yourself I
just want to find the worst one like I
gotta know you can't finish yeah it's
got it right now it's X arm so right now
the worst one I've seen is X arms exam
is that it's not so bad and it's good
it's just bad it's just [ __ ] boring
it's just bad it's boring yeah which is
a shame because like I've read the Manga
and it's actually not bad yeah it's just
the anime adaptation I don't know what
the [ __ ] happened they just I looked it
up so hard I looked it up they hired a
guy who had never like the director had
never done animation they hired like
someone who does real movies and like
action movies yeah and assumed he could
make it work in animation right and he
couldn't
yeah
Jesus Christ it's just for me the part
kills me with Exxon it's just like right
from the first episode is the fact that
like the main character is 3D well
everyone else is totally good it's the
most I haven't watched it oh my gosh I'm
not gonna like it it is the most jarring
thing to watch it's so bad it's crazy
take some screenshots and these two
characters are oh yeah different
dimensions
why why is that is there a reason or is
it just lazy they had two they had
multiple Studios doing it so one of them
that didn't x-arm I think also did Elden
ring like uh they did some of the art
for Eldon ring what really
like the studio was good I think it was
Elden ring I looked it up it has an
interesting story actually on how it
ended up being such a disaster
just gave it to the interns
I think it was just like a perfect storm
where probably yeah nobody knew what
they were working on they just kept
getting different and conflicting
directions from the upper level yeah and
I think like because I think it was it a
crunch roll original Yep
they're all like oh no it's uh I
remember when the ads started rolling
too crunch are all made sure to tell you
it was a crunch roll that's that's odd
like why do they not see it and just
think yeah we should maybe not advertise
this much that's what I always find most
interesting because you push it you know
it's bad like there's no one there that
knows it's there thinks it's good maybe
it's just like deals like priorities
it's got to be just yeah yeah because no
no way would you be like yeah let's yeah
I think it's good to go yeah
promoting okay yeah let's do it like I
would hate to be in that boardroom where
they get the first train they were like
I'm gonna air this
was just like oh yeah so it looks really
good um I assume you're gonna do the
finishing touches
oh my God